gas bubbling up over an area of more
than one square kilometer in the Baltic
Sea near the Danish island of bornholm
three huge leaks detected at both north
stream 1 and 2 is too much of a
coincidence according to European
leaders and energy experts
we see clearly that this is an act of
sabotage an act which likely means a
further step of escalation of the
situation in Ukraine Swedish
seismologists say they recorded two
explosions before the leaks were
detected one on Sunday night and one on
Monday evening it's not an earthquake
that's very clear and we also have quite
a lot of data on blasts in the water in
in the area slightly closer to the
Swedish Coast when the Swedish Navy have
training exercises and and they blast
off mines for example and they often let
us know about the particulars of that so
the data from yesterday's blasts are
very similar there's no doubt that these
are explosions occurring in the water
Germany has not been receiving any gas
from these pipelines for the last few
weeks when Russia stopped supplies
through North stream one North stream 2
never started operations Germany decided
to pull the block just before Russia
invaded Ukraine in February the north
stream pipelines have been at the heart
of an ongoing dispute on how dependent
Europe and specifically Germany have
become on Russian gas calls grew on
Germany to stop buying Russian gas into
the invasion of Ukraine but it was
Russia not Germany it has decided to
completely pass the supply of North
stream 1 just a few weeks ago but now
they're seriously damaged it's clear
that no Russian gas will flow through
these pipelines anytime soon
the leaks show Once More how vulnerable
Europe's energy Supply is and how
vulnerable the gas pipes are to attacks
technically speaking this is not
difficult I mean you it just requires a
boat it requires some divers that know
how to handle explosive devices
um and then depending on the water depth
uh there may be some special diving
equipment
or you could do it with some some of
those modern underwater submarines with
Ukraine blaming Russia for sabotaging
the pipelines others have been more
careful in pointing the finger before
more investigations stop fasten Al
Jazeera and Lupine on the Baltic Coast